what really struck me about Dover was
the number of very reasonable pragmatic
people saying look we can deal with
brexit but we need to know what we're
planning for we need some clarity and
that clarity just doesn't seem to be
happening I think that's obviously true
isn't it I mean you you if you are a
business and I just met with the
employers and my constituency on
Thursday evening if you're a business
you just actually tell us what we're
supposed to be doing the thing about
businesses you could put a boulder up in
front of them they'll find a way around
it or through it or underneath it or
over it but they just need to know what
that Boulder looks like so we need to
have clarity on what bricks it's going
to look like it's frankly because it's
living complicated things to do and you
know after thinking it through a lot I
voted remain narrowly my heart wanted to
leave but my head was remain because I
always thought this is going to be
unbelievably complex to disentangle
ourselves from 45 years of being in the
EU and so it is but that doesn't mean
that we we can't do it and I think it
can be successful but we do have to
decide on some of these fundamentals and
you know tell us and tell the country
Parliament government and tell business
what we're gonna do of course it's
complicated no one would disagree with
the fact that leaving the EU is
complicated but at the same time in one
of the kind of big challenges of your
generation of politicians it feels as
though the Conservative Party is
effectively in turmoil I mean what's
happening is it a leadership issue well
I look I don't things just the
Conservative Party that struggles over
this cuz you're the government they want
news that's true but let's just look at
it as it really is the country right is
completely split on this so if you want
to have a party there's representative
country here's one argument you know the
Conservative Party spit on it the Labour
Party split on it actually mostly
families you know disagree I know with
my family it's so a heated debate often
to discuss break so people are not in
agreement on this and so you can't
expect political parties to necessarily
be in agreement but that doesn't mean
that there isn't a solution and I think
that there there are things that can be
done to make sure that when we are out
of Europe was still able to trade and I
think we just have to
like this there are 500 million people
in the right of which Britain's a
component part of that but there are
seven billion people in the world at
large and we have two real orientate
ourselves to think about that wider 7
billion market and get the best possible
deal meanwhile with Europe you're saying
of course that people are split on
brexit and do you think Tereza nation
perhaps just forget the kind of
squabbling cabinet ministers and just
make some decisions I think actually
what's really interesting is whenever
Teresa maze made a speech like the
Florence speech or one of those big set
pieces people have actually after said
oh yeah that's that's okay we can go
along with that and whether they're
brexit ears or remain as they've kind of
felt that they could get them behind it
and the lesson is simple actually when
she does make decisions people do tend
to feel that at least there's a sense of
direction so yeah more more of that
would definitely be helped it's it's
interesting because your tone seems to
have shifted since last year when you
famously of course launched her a bit of
a coup against tourism a it didn't
really work and to put it kindly so have
you have you changed your mind on first
of all a bunch of colleagues wanted to
speak to the Prime Minister because
things weren't exactly going right we'd
had a botched election and a rather
uninspiring conference by the awesome
people were pretty fed up but actually
the reality is that time moves on
changes have been made so we've got now
I think you know a party organization
which is a lot better than the Brandon
Lewis we've got changes made in in
Downing Street
you know better a better set up and so
actually I think you know progress is
and has been made as well well they're
all these factors new you got you know
as we're discussing a deep in decision
about which direction we should take on
things like brakes it's there's not an
obvious alternative but actually as
you're just saying when trees are made
takes a decision people actually go oh
okay well I may not agree with all of
that but you know what the decisions
been made I'm prepared to follow I think
where the problem comes when things are
allowed to float and drift and decisions
are made and that's when you tend to get
to these kind of heated up moments we
take this week for example we've got the
bill coming back to Parliament this is
the famous brexit bill that's been in
the Lord's 15 changes have been made
I don't personally see a problem with
having one or two dates fact it's two
days to bait on this and actually I hope
voting it back just as it was before
cause we've already as a parliament gone
through line by line by line and agreed
all this stuff so why shouldn't we just
vote it back through again a couple of
amendments come back from the Lord's but
basically vote it through again I think
that's what will happen and it's a good
example of where the decisions made
bring it back to the house
let the house aside let's move on so
what would you say to your colleagues
who would disagree with that they think
that actually this is something that is
too important to just move on to just
vote in a way that they don't but first
we had eight days of detailed
line-by-line debate on every single one
of these aspects that's that's been
turned over by the House of Lords
secondly actually when I'm speaking to
colleagues and you saw this morning and
people on different sized debates brexit
Aaron Ian Duncan Smith remain is coming
together and actually agreeing that we
should just get this bit of the stage
through you talking to right at the
beginning about those businesses in
Dover who want to have the certainty
part of that certainty can be provided
by Parliament getting on and providing
it and actually that of course requires
you know the Prime Minister and the
government to be bringing the stuff back
to the that the House of Commons decide
on and then that actually does provide
the certainty of people need and just
finally before you leave us do you think
trees may will lead us into the next
general election leave the Conservative
Party into the next I think the
interesting thing says you know six
months ago a year ago people were saying
after that failed election because she's
only got till next March when we
actually leave I don't think many people
now is saying she's going to leave in
March because you've got then a
negotiation period till the end of 2020
possibly 2021 we learned this week I
think it's perfectly conceivable now
likely that no but conceivable that she
leads us into the next election and I
think potentially even wins that
election so I think it is possible and
but we do need to have got more
decisions made less waiting around for
things get things out in front of
Parliament not impossible maybe 30 40
percent 30 40 percent got chaps thank
you very much